All right, interviews.
Got lots of good candidates.
Let's dive right in.
I think you might have actually just muted yourself right there.
A little about myself...
...really driven.
Hey, sorry, Tim. I think you might be having some webcam issues.
Kind of looks like you're whistling.
Now it seems like you're going backwards; that's the first time I've seen that.
Sounds like you're speaking in tongues and everything's gotten really dark.
I like to think of myself as a passionate...
Never mind.
So, Jen, why do you want to work for this company?
I would be thrilled to work with you. Hey! No, dear, can you stop right now?
I need to do this interview so I can pay for your food.
Oh, so cute.
So, Tim, what would you say is your biggest strength?
People say that I'm too organized at times and I can see where they get it.
I mean, I consider myself a neat freak.
For sure.
Hey, do you mind moving a little closer to the camera?
Just a little closer, I can't see.
Is this better?
Yeah, that's better,...
...but now I kind of see the bottom of your chin.
Now I'm just kind of seeing the tippy top of your head.
Hey, where's he going?
I guess we're going on a journey.
So, Katie, how would you say you stay calm in stressful situations?
Great question.
How I stay calm in stressful...
One second.